so total diffuse language annotation at
YouTube which you guys know there means
a train develop something I'm trying to
set a foundation on top of which we can
build right so remember if you have some
function of X which is call F function
but of course you can call anything pick
your own G or H or a or it's just a
label given that function we define the
gradient function and we thought hijack
function notation right so we say look
the gradient function is a function so
therefore I could write it like this
right you input an x value and you will
get out an output which is the grade
okay we indicate the - to say look it's
like FX it's related but it's not
something we call the derivative because
it comes from proceeds from the original
function and then we feel this fancy
geometry with rise over run the secant
and tangent to come up with this right
hand side over here which is a bit of a
mess but it just said two important
pieces
what was the trusted I'll give you a
clue it starts with them now yeah I had
a right to limit the very first thing we
have to write down is a limit because we
want a change it at a single point not a
speaker at two points right so we want
the distance between each two points to
zero and then what follows is this
fraction before you tell you what's in
the fraction what is the fraction was
representing which is gradient just rise
over run in the particular setup that we
had the rise was what FX + H
and you take away MX so there's your
rhymes the run of course is going to be
this form of listen to edge let me have
a little note blood to this it's not the
only way to write this for example
because this little distance here is a
horizontal distance it's just a change
in X it's just the change in X so
sometimes you'll see this written and
the limit got as H approaches zero but
as Delta X approaches 0 again trying to
go back to this idea of Delta V
indicating a little change just to
change okay therefore you can feel the
right-hand side well everywhere you saw
HS you will write Delta X in step so
this would be f of X plus Delta X and on
the bottom of X okay
you won't see this as frequently this is
far more common mr. :
95% of the times you will speak this
principle in a textbook or exam or in
working this is what you see and
occasionally you see is I hope it's just
a fake thing dressed up slightly to
presume there is one more form that I
want to show you which is probably more
important this will be further this
lesson which is that we just described
these two points X and X plus h which is
like a little bit further right as the
two points on our speaker right well you
can think of another version of this you
can think about what happens if you've
got two completely different points
let's just call one of the C and one of
the banks right so you've got one point
of view speaker well point at the
beginning and what you really want is to
bring them close together so as C
approaches X you go from a secant to a
teacher does that make sense
what you get on the right-hand side is
exactly the same as what you have for
it's just to rise over run
right except instead it will be make
sure I get my water bottle because
there's a couple extra expenses pretty
sure today yeah it's good MC and X the X
can you see this is say hey this is just
a same thing right it's still rise
everyone
it's just that two slightly different
spots bless you okay okay so all these
kinds of things the great function is
the way we described it the other name
which we said started with a D was the
derivative because it came from the
original budget and alternative word
right yeah what'd you use my password
yeah sure okay but let's get right to
that so give it f of X you know
everything is in function notation but
if you get given something else if given
y equals something you can write another
function of X okay now instead of using
F dash like if there s recently to the
label for apps so you can't say F dash
the mark will say what's F right in this
case why is the label now I can use this
notation that - there I could use it
just like I did over here right so I can
take Y - is the gradient function is the
derivative
moving further than that while I take
questions you are near it--let wipers
why better if I say let y equal f of X
like that
can you see having written this I now
can use either of these right because Y
and f of X have booked the introduced
now so I can use Y - like I just stuck
here I could use F - because they are
after all different labels for the same
in that example now let me just put a
quick note
you will see this river you're set in
advance your Sears in textbooks you need
to recognize but sometimes why - what
they're talking about
that's why I'm telling you about it but
I am going to discourage you from ever
writing it here's why if I said to you
artex how do you read that just a lot of
rhetorical question how you read it
expect sure how about this how do you
read that sounds fine to me how about
that looks like X to the power of 11
right doesn't it
what about that
now at least I'm sure I'm not the only
one when I'm writing by just normal
handwriting my wives and my dashing look
identical if you type them they just
look slightly different a - looks
something like this kind of got a bit of
a rounded bit at the top and then it
quickly at the bottom whereas if you
type 1 if you know devil's Sarris and
all that kind of thing but when we write
it when we write it as which exactly the
same okay so I'm going to discourage you
from everybody this because as you're
going to see you later this lesson we
sometimes being that isn't one and then
other times a minute that is - like are
you asking to communicate in an unclear
way and be confusing so I never write
this except for when I'm telling people
what it means that when you read it and
you see this you know what you're
talking about okay if you have wives in
here if it's far more preferable to say
D Y on D X what does that mean again
what it mean it's a changing Y over the
change in it's just a fancy way of
saying by the wrong
now this last thing here raises of you
think a new ID really good which is that
I want you to now think about why being
some functions okay
the while DX is the derivative the
gradient function okay but if you look
carefully at this it's kind of like the
process of differentiating is written as
this part of the notation do you see
that there's a data type and then
there's an on DX and then the Y is what
you're applying this process to right
that's the process of differentiating so
therefore the on DX is like sign or
cause or log in that is something which
you can put other things into it we have
it we call it the differential operator
because the differential operator
because the thing it does is
differentiate we caught the differential
operator because it does and it operates
on something it has a function right as
opposed to say will at you know similar
to sign this is an operator as well that
doesn't mean anything on its own you
have to say sign of what you say sine of
X or sine of theta right but sign on its
own
doesn't mean anything cuz it's an
operator let's say log log base 2 log
base 2 of what you have to supply some
kind of value in there right since
you're over here don't do what I used to
do in Alexander 11 because I didn't know
what this thing was I just thought Oh
questions are asking me to differentiate
this is the thing that says depreciate
so I write things like this blah blah
blah
this doesn't make sense
because there's nothing here being
differentiated okay so the way I read
this is depreciate whatever comes next
and if I have a wider like this then it
means differentiate that function just
Atticus but of course as a shorthand
rather than writing the white over there
we tend to write a pop on the top just
so it looks like the rise over one the
weaponry so far so good